et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
florian philippot président des
patriotes bonsoir bonsoir à vos côtés
gab alabina cofondateur du mouvement des
droits civiques bonsoir alors gérald
darmanin on le disait de renforcer
l'apprentissage de l'arabe à l'école une
proposition républicaine et courageuse
affirme le ministre de l'intérieur vous
partager son opinion en amalgame inas et
une bonne proposition et révélations oui
c'est une excellente proposition
simplement parce que d'abord l'ignorance
cents héros de la radicalisation et que
lorsqu'on apprend l'arabe dans la langue
et de l'esprit on a la possibilité
d'apprendre la civilisation arabe arabo
musulmane pour être précis puisque la
plupart des maghrébins sont plutôt de
civilisation arabo-musulmane et cet
apprentissage permettre effectivement
donner un éclairage nouveau
alors culture qui ne connaissent que
très peu et permettrait surtout de tes
fils php les tensions et de sortir des
de la profession réclame alors florian
philippot l'arabe est déjà une langue
vivante a enseigné à l'école délaissé
vendons la preuve dans le programme de
l'éducation nationale finalement
accentuer cette proposition
effectivement est ce que cela peut
éviter aux jeunes d'aller apprendre
l'arabe à la mosquée ou dans des écoles
coraniques et puis avec un enseignement
ou non mais dans le contexte également
de la culture quel est votre regard sur
cette proposition florian philippot non
j'y suis très défavorable je pense que
c'est très étonnant de partir dans un
débat sur le séparatisme soi disant pour
lutter contre le séparatisme en
commençant par justement une mesure qui
sépare enfin ce qui unit c'est la langue
nationale si vous voulez si on veut que
ces jeunes qui qui sont issus de
l'immigration ou dans les parents est
issu d'une migration soit la nation
française il faudra apprendre le
français
et on sait que c'est la langue nationale
et on sait que le français
malheureusement est de moins en moins
bien écrit et parlé
calé problèmes à l'école à l'école
primaire il faut donc mettre le paquet
beaucoup plus sur le français ça me
semble être la priorité absolue pour
tous les jeunes les enfants de france en
quelle que soit leur origine
évidemment et c'est comme ça que mon
facilitera l'intégration et
l'assimilation la langue arabe
c'est une longue un d'importance et de
culture qui doit être apprise en france
comme peut l'être le japonais le persan
le chinois ou d'autres uniquement
partir du secondaire je le pense mais je
pense que c'est parfaitement
contreproductif
vous savez les religieux trouveraient
toujours où les radicaux d'autres
prétextes pour avoir accès à ces jeunes
si ça n'est pas l'apprentissage de
l'arabe
ils ne diront que c'est
l'approfondissement de l'apprentissage
de l'arabe où ils trouveront bien
d'autres choses ne savais pas du tout la
réponse adéquate à l'orgue amalgamer n'a
effectivement qu'est ce que vous
répondez à florian philippot qui nous
dit ben mettons le paquet sur ce que sur
ce qui unit aujourd'hui à l'école à
savoir la langue française quelle est
votre réponse
la réponse est très simple d'abord c'est
le promotion de lattes de la culture
depuis quand le fait d'apprendre
plusieurs langues réduit la qualité
d'apprendre une langue ça n'a aucun sens
j'ai envie de dire à monsieur furieux
physiquement qu'on dit souvent nos
ancêtres les gaulois pour faire
décoratifs même au niveau des postes
colonisés mais que le gaulois a comparé
cette langue ancienne
on a récupéré que sans mordant le
français alors que l'arabe à mille mots
je préfère la lys abricots bananes et
autres mais bon quoi qu'il en soit déjà
le français est déjà tâté d'arabité
culturellement et c'est normal c'est
françois 1er qui avait ouvert la porte à
cette voie c'est surtout la présence
arabe en espagne et dans le sud de la
france à narbonne pour une centaine
d'années mais au delà de ça c'est
surtout la langue du commerce à l'époque
et je suis très étonné que vous ne
parliez pas de l'anglais par exemple
sont neuf mois voudra-t-il vous poser de
problème de vous dire que peut-être
l'anglais est trop parler d'école ça
c'est pas un problème puisque c'est une
culture occidentale peut-être et puis je
ne vois pas en voir - prendrait mieux
que puissent apprendre
évidemment qu'il faut que les gens par
le dial français et c'est une
défaillance du système scolaire actuel
qui fait qu'il ya des écoles d'élite
ainsi henri cazes henry cap par exemple
vous allez école de banlieue qu'il
s'ouvre on se souvent sur les écoles de
seconde zone
on apprend plus grand-chose même pas le
français mais au delà du français puis
surtout je suis étonné parce que
l'apprentissage des premières langues
dans la prime enfance c'est le meilleur
moyen d'accéder à la langue et de la
culture
je ne sais pas si vous parlez l'anglais
moi j'ai la chance par laurent bellet de
connaître lire et écrire l'arabe c'est
un parcours du combattant mais c'est pas
l'école de la pluie qui m'a donné cette
chance à g a pris ailleurs il a pris le
pass par les mosquées la mosquée de
paris en l'occurrence il a fallu que
j'ai la chance une fois dans l'école la
république d'avoir un directeur
d'ailleurs je salue monsieur cochet qui
a eu l'intelligence de nous donner des
cours d'arabe à l'école de la république
j'étais petit j'avais 12 ans c'est comme
ça que j'applique tueur la richesse de
parler plusieurs langues permet d'ouvrir
les esprits et quand on ouvre à l'esprit
est bien on est beaucoup moins perméable
à des idées radicales et il est
difficile de
voir que vous fassiez la promotion du
manquement de connaissances en matière
de de la connaissance de plusieurs jeux
d'hier les français veulent apprendre
les clients étrangers parlent que
l'anglais quasiment aucune langue
étrangère
et moi je pense qu'il faut faire la
promotion je suis étonné de ce que vous
dites là avec florian philippot non je
crois que vous confondez tout moi je
suis très favorable à ce qu'on apprenne
des langues étrangères je suis pas
favorable à ce qu'on réapprenne les
langues dites mortes comme le latin ou
le grec qui ont été complètement
abandonné et je suis y compris favrat
parce que des gens qui veulent apprendre
un peu plus âgé l'arabe le russe le
chinois sera puisse le faire mais je
pense que ça n'est pas le lieu de
l'école primaire
vous savez les horaires tout simplement
pour vous répondre ne sont pas
extensibles
si vous mettez une heure ou deux heures
par semaine d' arabes vous allez enlever
une heure ou deux heures ailleurs parce
que les enfants voient là ont des
horaires évidemment et leurs enseignants
aussi or il faut mettre le paquet sur le
français à l'école primaire parce que
quand on a entre 6 et 10 ans c'est là
qu'on doit apprendre parfaitement à
maîtriser sa langue à l'écrit comme à
l'oral est la langue de la fuite la
langue française c'est le français c'est
comme ça et je crois que c'est comme
cela que l'on fera une nation ne fait
pas semblant que ne parler simplement de
l'apprentissage des langues moi je parle
anglais je parle allemand je suis ravi
de parler ces langues et j'encourage
tout le monde à apprendre des langues
étrangères et vous avez raison sur un
point la sueur focalisation sur l'anglo
américain est un problème et je ne suis
pas favorable à ce qu'on apprend on sur
apprennent l'anglo-américain à l'école
primaire certainement pas je pense qu'il
faut se concentrer sur le français mais
là on voit bien que le risque c'est la
dérive communautariste c'est quoi
certains apprendront l'arabe
parce que ils sont d'origine arabe ou
parce que leurs parents le sont et on va
renforcer le séparatisme la
ghettoïsation et je pense que c'est tout
à fait l'inversé de ce qu'il faut faire
alors voilà à nouveau ajourné à les y
voilà donc déjà je ne confonds pas tout
une capacité à pékin qui permet de
partir je pense que vous dites et
surtout de ceux de vous ramener un petit
peu à quelques réalités je vous dis que
la prime enfance permet d'assimiler
mieux les langues pas la langue l'élan
dont semble pas que quand on l'enfant
sort de l'as de delacroix dire du cp cm1
il sait pas parler français le sait
après l'amélioration des qualités en
terme de maîtrise de la langue se perd à
partir de la sixième à la troisième dans
les établissements de seconde zone et
vous les connaissez très bien je
prétends que ces articles
quand on rentre à henri iv on n'a pas de
problème de langue vous le savez très
bien parce qu'on est à paris moi j'ai eu
la chance d'être à l'école à paris ça
fait une différence mais je sais ce que
c'est que l'école dans l'est
cousins et cousines ont subi l'école des
banlieues je parle de la banlieue est
républicaine
vous confondez vous en revanche le fait
d'avoir de la culture et d'élargir sa
culture avec un esprit beaucoup plus
flexible sous le col et finalement j'ai
parcouru l'article
on n'a pas retenu la langue dit claire
on a retenu la langue de goethe je pense
que je vous reprocherai jamais de parler
allemand parce qu'à mon sens c'est une
très belle langue et riche qui a nourri
l'anglais chaos nourrir français aussi
falloir donc ça c'est une chose et
deuxième chose concernant
l'apprentissage
évidemment que c'est l'enfance ils
veulent apprendre un défaut en france et
qu'on apprend sur le tard d'élan on ne
maîtrise pas j'ai pas vu je vais pas
vous expliquer à quel point les français
quand il compte à l'étranger se couvre
de ridicule quand il articule par guido
trois mots d'anglais d'espagnol de
français
la france est plus ou moins approximatif
que je vous parle pas l'espagnol et
l'anglais
donc tout ça pour vous dire que il faut
sortir de super amis qui lui
conseillaient à dire le français domine
c'est fini le français qui était une
langue l'arabe d'ailleurs au demeurant
langue de diplomatie on a conservé sa le
à l'onu pour la décoration
le français est en perte de vitesse
parce que naturellement et c'est comme
ça c'est le jeu de la puissance
économique c'est l'état unique de vous
bientôt les états unis seront perdus
vitesse parce que ce sera le mandarin
chinois qui l'a dominé mais quoi qu'il
en soit on connaît les paradis dire que
la cinquième langue la plus parlée au
monde qui en plus à un vecteur qui
religieux comme vous parliez du latin
tout à leurs vecteurs religieux de
catholicisme et du fils yen l'euro perd
et bien l'arabe secteur religieux qui
cela bien on a deux systèmes on al islam
éclairé qui réfléchit qui s'ouvre celui
de tales kindy celui de blé connexes on
sent qu'ils ont été latinisé pour cool
quand on parle de la vie saine quand on
parle d'averroès rouge et de cinar a
tout comme quand on parle des extraits
n'orientent orientaux du type on parle
souvent par exemple confucius c'est pas
son nom son prénom chinois n'est pas
confucius vous avez été chercher ça
c'est une façon de se réapproprier la
culture orientale qui plaisait aux
orientalistes et d'oublier que les gens
ne se grandissent que lorsqu'ils ont
enfin réapproprier tous leurs aspects
culturels qui sont multiples et variées
et c'est en ce cas je vous dis
qu'effectivement la défaillance du
système français c'est pas d'avoir deux
ans depuis arabe ou d'anglais ou
d'espagnol en primaire c'est de ne pas
les avoir si florian philippot vous
répondez tout de suite juste avant je
voulais vous montrer la déclaration de
gérald darmanin ce week-end dans le
journal du dimanche à propos de cet
enseignement à l'école regarder alors
l'enseigné à l'école c'est aussi réduire
le pouvoir des religieux
voilà ça vient voilà l enseigne à
l'école c'est aussi le pouvoir de
réduire par dont le pouvoir des
religieux comment vous le comprenez et
florian philippot oui j'avais entendu
cet argument qui avaient répondu dans la
première intervention je pense que c'est
une c'est une bêtise parce que les
religieux ceux qui veulent endoctrinés
des jeunes le front le trouveront
toujours prétexte à un prétexte par la
langue ou par un autre aspect de sport
n'importe quoi ils trouveront toujours
un moyen je pense que c'est pas du tout
un argument valable pour vous répondre
vous êtes dans une logique
multiculturaliste en fait vous dites
voilà qui est un enfant doit à condom
tous les aspects de sa culture y compris
quand en fait il n'a vécu qu'en france
donc en fait voulu empêcher de pouvoir
s'assimiler à la nation française
vous avez le ghettoïser vous allez le
force l'assigné à résidence culturel en
quelque sorte y compris à un pays qui
donne à une civilisation qui est tout à
fait respectable mais qui n'a absolument
pas reconnu il peut être même pas ses
parents et alors vous allez l'empêché
d'être parfaitement intégré à la france
en parlant le français et vous dites que
le français la langue française est
maîtrisée à l'école malheureusement non
et on le sait qu'elle l'est de moins en
moins il faut donc mettre le paquet et
je le redis sur le français la moitié de
l'apprentissage
je crois à l'école primaire devrait se
faire aujourd'hui d'abord et avant tout
sur le français à l'oral et à l'écrit
parce qu'il est très mal au moins en
moins bien le maîtriser et c'est là que
celui que naissent les principes et les
inégalités sociales aujourd'hui c'est
dans la maîtrise de la langue nationale
entre un cv bien rédigé en français et
un cv mal rédigée par ce que la langue
n'a pas été maîtrisée et bien
l'employeur choisira le bon cv et donc
vous allez creuser les perpétuer dans
une égalité sociale il faut absolument
mettre le paquet ça n'empêche pas à
l'apprentissage des langues étrangères
c'est un autre débat
l'ouverture sur la condition des
civilisations des langues étrangères des
langues mortes etc
c'est un autre débat il faut
l'encourager mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec ce que propose darmanin est ce que
vous dites également en filigramme kamal
habib à regarder également le voilà
répondait peut-être avant on va écouter
le commentaire des manuels macro à ce
sujet vous répondez juste après donc le
commentaire de manuel macro à ce sujet
nous attaquer c'est le séparatisme
islamistes c'est le coeur du sujet
les jeunes vont apprendre l'arabe dans
des associations qui leur propose le
pire est qu'ils sont manipulés le
séparatisme islamique pour islamistes
pointé du doigt par emmanuel macron
c'est le coeur du sujet explique le
président il a raison gamme à la villa
et rapidement juste pour remettre les
pendules à l'heure le multiculturalisme
n'est pas une insulte c'est une richesse
si vous préférez être réduit par les
trois ça m'étonne de vous elle ne paraît
qu'une seule langue c'est très
surprenant et juste pour votre
information le chômage qui touche les
banlieues 40 % à 40 % thuringe en
banlieue ça n'est pas parce qu'il écrit
ce pas le français puisque souvent des
gens très qualifiés n'ont pas accès à
l'emploi c'est parce qu'il a un problème
aux qui s'appelle le sectarisme raciste
ou simplement
et ça c'est un problème doit être réglé
en profondeur à savoir comment parler
d'intégration
j'aime bien l'insertion sociale comment
laisser des gens qui travaillaient on le
voit bien avec le beurre les jeunes de
banlieue sont précipités par une voix
qui leur était ouverte
le travail ensuite concernant le fait de
parler plusieurs langues c'est une
richesse qui vous permet par exemple
d'aller à dubaï ça veut dire tout bête
mais tous ceux qui partent à dubaï qui
parle un peu l'arabe aujourd'hui sont
libérés de ces questions du chômage donc
le poème pas de savoir si on doit pas se
connaître la culture d'origine
on doit connaître plusieurs cultures et
je suis multiculturaliste et fier de
l'être parce que c'est une richesse vous
vous réduisez à une seule culture c'est
bien triste
bien que riche cette culture elle n'est
pas la culture centrales du monde et
c'est normal puisqu'elle a fait son
temps chaque culture fait son temps et
s'allège à d'autres cultures et c'est
pas à prendre à une expression orale
voyez le maîtrisent parfaitement
français sinon mieux que vous et pour
autant j'ai patrouillé travail j'ai créé
mon entreprise parce que je sais ce que
c'est l'exclusion concernant le
séparatisme islamique dont le sumac on
parle alors ces dépôts aux effets de
manche très mignon de le dire mais c'est
une façon de ne pas parler des vrais
points qui fâchent aujourd'hui on a une
détresse économique type qui est très
puissant très marquée au relais ce qui
se passe et que les bars les restaurants
on voit aussi qu'il ya aussi une non
maîtrise de cette crise sanitaire qui
fait paniquer tout le mond littéralement
parce que ma part l'état major ne sont
plus en mesure de pouvoir y répondre il
suffit de voir l'état dans lequel sont
les états unis et la france à proportion
égale et dans les bêtas et pour finir ce
séparatisme et pas mythe qui permet une
fois de plus sept principaux
qu'émissaire de montrer du doigt autre
chose pour pas montré des vrais
problèmes et les gilet jaune ne s'y sont
pas trompé lorsqu'il manifester parce
qu'ils ont bien compris que la question
des banlieues était marginal par rapport
à la propre pour les matières qui était
social aurions fini pau le mot de la fin
pour conclure
bah vous savez y aura pas suffisamment
d'emplois à dubai pour tout le monde
donc l'otan essayez de
les emplois ici et je maintiens que le
souvent le problème de l'accès à
l'emploi c'est un non maîtrise du
français là vous vous trompez où vous
voulez tromper littéralement les gens et
quant à vos considérations sur la
culture française qui serait donc
terminés ou en voie d'être l'envoi des
réactions je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec vous c'est une trés et de
grandes cultures une très belle culture
et j'aimerais que les français quelles
que soient leurs origines connaissent
beaucoup mieux l'étendue magnifique de
notre culture de nos arts de notre
littérature de notre théâtre et de tout
ce qui fait la richesse de notre pays
mais je moi je suis très attaché à ce
que nous soyons fiers une effusion notre
culture française vous vous êtes
d'accord avec max fonds pour dire que la
culture française n'existe pas c'est
votre droit mais pèse de multiples de
faire la liste suivante êtes vous avez à
la fin quand on est multiculturelle il
ya plus de culture on ne maîtrise rien
du tout on saute il de culture en
culture et on n'a pas de culture et on
se retrouve en bourg b englobé dans le
mondialisme avec sa langue et sa langue
se sera pas l'arabe ce sera l'anglo
américain je vous l'annonçais de tout de
suite donc je pense que ce soit ce que
vous dites est profondément naïf soit
vous dissimuler votre jeu mais il est
évident que ré apprendre l'arabe aux
enfants d'origine étrangère ou dont les
parents étaient d'origine étrangère est
allé à l'école est un moyen de séparer
de casser le pays d' empêcher
l'intégration et l'assimilation de faire
avancer au contraire l'islamisme le
croit à la fin et le séparatisme
le communautarisme et non pas de faire
une nation et est de permettre à la
france d'être unis c'est une évidence
pour moi j'ai eu la langue c'est le
ciment premier d'une nation et c'est
pour cela que la langue française est
tellement attaqué y compris par les
communautaristes des séparatistes que
vous allez représenter ce soir dans ce
débat merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté le jeu du débat merci à vous
florian philippot je rappelle que vous
êtes président des patriotes merci à
vous amalgame dynaco fondateur du
mouvement des droits civiques